okay here's the deal alright Pam says
that one of the Alliance's is meeting in
the warehouse during Meredith's birth my
god we have to be there I know but it's
gonna be a little tough because there's
no good place to hide yes there is
behind the shelves oh my god what what
why I know I know exactly what to do
great
I'm a deer hunter I go all the time with
my dad one thing about deer they have
very good vision one thing about me I am
better at hiding than they are at vision
this is gonna be perfect okay centrally
located perfect cover I can hear and see
everything good wait this isn't gonna
work the lids open so tape it down I
can't do that then you won't be able to
breathe look I can breathe just fine
okay but if it makes you feel better
I'll poke holes in the box thank you
thank you okay so you want me to stay
here and you know stand next to the box
no you need to go upstairs to the party
so people don't notice that we're both
gone right that's good
can I trust Jim I don't know do I have a
choice no frankly I don't will I trust
Jim yes should I trust Jim you tell me
he's in a box he's in a box he's
downstairs in a box on the floor near
the shelves I'm serious go down there
magic hey where are you yeah we were
supposed to meet here what oh my gosh
that ties in perfectly was something
that Michael was telling me earlier I
just don't know what some of the people
in like accounting are gonna do it said
specifically
[Music]
you